welcome to the Americas lectures the
series entitled exigencies go either way
either way no either way exigencies from
impermanent emergencies to enduring
expectations I am pleased to introduce
we go way back many decades although I
still consider something of a Thomas
there you could stop now
of our time but to put in that Clark for
him and for that specialty is to suggest
iris versatility in his range during his
career he's all over the place and these
topics and embassies and the broad that
he is mastered and contributed so much
to I mean his topic this series is it's
different and it's new and it could
hardly be more important as emergencies
exigencies and the third leg phobia is
entitled negotiating the role of law
[Applause]
it is good I'm gonna do so I'm what
we've just done in this room is confirm
the only hypothesis and the social
sciences always to be confirmed it's Tom
shelling a great student of game theory
and the like says that when people come
to a lecture and there are more seats
than people then it's individually
rational for people to sit to the rear
but if if people follow their individual
level rationality collectively you have
a sub optimal outcome so if you'll
indulge me I'm gonna ask people in the
back to come forward how's that if I may
mr. chairman yeah that way we have a
more intimate occasion we need another
shelling hypothesis about how much
forward people will come but then ever
and now we're making room for some more
people coming in good a lot of people
a very big group just can't walk in
their choice about me I don't know where
they've all come from so this is
cinematic you understand those have just
come in have missed the most gracious of
introductions by my dear friend and
colleague David may you you forgot to do
one thing you said I am
sterling professor emeritus but you
didn't say I'm David Mayer but everyone
at Yale knows that but everyone knows
that dear David it's a really a more
than a treat a very special honor to be
introduced by Professor may-who who's
without whose example those of us who
care and think about American politics
would be much weaker in our instruments
and capacities to know how to enter into
complicated topics and especially anyone
daring to work on Congress is more
indebted to Professor Mayhew than to
literally anyone else so thank you dear
David for that introduction the content
the contest between the good of
protecting the country from danger and
the good of remaining within the
confines of ordinary lawful political
processes is not new this field of
tension has challenged leaders and
citizens from the earliest moments of
liberal government in the United States
two decades after the ratification of
the Constitution on September 14th 1810
Thomas Jefferson was asked by John
Colvin quote are there not periods when
in free governments
it is necessary for officers in
responsible stations to exercise an
authority beyond the law and was not the
time of Aaron burrs treason just such a
period jefferson replied six days later
affirming that leaders have an
obligation and I quote of saving our
country when in danger he swiftly added
how quote overleaping the law often is a
far greater evil than a strict adherence
to its imperfect provisions so
overleaping the law is can be a great
evil given this inherent tension
jefferson stipulated how in navigating
the rule of law and I quote the line of
discrimination between cases may be
difficult when Robert Dahl identified a
class of situations in 1953 quote for
which the traditional democratic
processes are rather unsuitable and for
which traditional theories of democracy
provide no rational answer a citation
some of you have heard me make now for
the third time finding that finding the
line of discrimination between cases
Wendall wrote had become vastly more
demanding by then anew and he surmised
permanent national security state had
been created after the first atomic bomb
was detonated at New Mexico's Test Site
zero on July 15 1945 then put to use to
end the war with Japan unlike the call
by Franklin Roosevelt in 1933 to wage a
war against the emergency with the
prospect of a return to a functioning
economy the institutional sinews of an
entirely new zone of public life were
shaped by lawmaking the periods landmark
legislation included the Atomic Energy
Act of nineteen
46 the National Security Act of 1947 the
defense reorganization Act of 1949 the
National Security Act another National
Security Act of 1950 and on nod
especially after the August 1949 Soviet
bomb and Kazakhstan ended America's
atomic monopoly and intensified a cold
war of indeterminate duration suspicions
grew loyalties were investigated
surveillance advanced secrecy expanded
but not without limits as Michael
Hogan's important history of the origins
of the post-war national security state
demonstrates the unification of the
Armed Forces the organization of the
Pentagon the harnessing of science for
weapons production the mobilization of
production and manpower the growth of an
intelligence community and other
unprecedented instruments of national
security
formed inside a crucible of democratic
debate and legislative contestation the
result hogan argued was a middle ground
the defense of Liberty understood in
terms of limiting the reach of the state
and the defense of Liberty understood in
terms of enhancing state power vied and
compromised but it must be said as Dahl
rightly emphasized that especially once
the Korean War commenced and military
spending accelerated the second impulse
advanced faster than the first power
shifted to the enlarging zone of
enduring exceptions the tradition of
civic authority that constrains
government by law protects individual
freedom secures private life and civil
society and prevents repressive search
and seizure among other rights thus was
placed under persistent pressure
the enemy without was fierce and
dangerous engaging with that enemy
placed enormous pressure on the
country's liberal democracy arguably
imposing more pressure than any time
since southern secession in 1949 Clinton
Rossiter announced as doll would four
years later quote that there is much to
fear in the Atomic Age and our fear is
the more naked because it touches on the
unknown dolls tone was measured marked
more by a descriptive sigh rather than
dramatic remonstration three decades
later after the hydrogen bomb after
intercontinental missiles after the
Cuban Missile Crisis the Vietnam War the
Pentagon Papers
revelations and the manifest durability
of secrecy surveillance and what
Eisenhower had called the
military-industrial complex dolls voice
transmuted to alarm when delivering the
abrams lectures that i mentioned
yesterday in 1984 at syracuse doll asked
whether and I quote the institutions of
contemporary democracy are adequate to
cope satisfactorily with the enormous
complexity of public matters and his
analysis shifted from raising a
fundamental question to announcing a
disturbing answer his early 1950s
nightmare he said had become fact doll
now observed how quote American policies
concerning nuclear weapons had been made
for the better part of 35 years without
hardly a trace of the adversarial
process a central feature of any vibrant
democracy he took note of and I quote a
tragic paradox no-decisions he wrote can
be more fateful for Americans and for
the world than decisions about nuclear
weapons yet these decisions have largely
escaped the ordinary constraints and
control of the democratic process
and he continued an uncommon li sharp
language we have on we have alienated
control over our lives to others that is
for practical purposes we simply have
lost control over crucial decisions and
lose control over our lives the more we
if you read this side by side with say
is preface the democratic theory that's
rather a different tone here the more we
a lien ADA thority rather than delegate
it on terms that allow us to retain a
meaningful degree of final control the
more we lose our freedom and the more
hollow the democratic process becomes
end quote yesterday I closed by posing
the question I should like to deal with
tonight at which point do exceptions
become a new norm and thus transform the
character and balance of the political
order from within this challenge I put
in the yesterday in terms presented by
Carl Schmitt the most incisive and
articulate analytical enemy of liberal
democracy in the twentieth century to
ask whether our country's enlarged zone
of exceptions can be governed in ways
that resemble what he called the
commissary 'el pattern of dictatorship a
form of exceptional rule geared to
strengthen an existing liberal
Constitution as distinct from what he
called sovereign dictatorship that
free-standing response to exigencies
outside the rule of law had moved from
the pages of his 1920s political thought
to stunning reality in non liberal
regimes especially the most radical
Stalin's USSR Hitler's Third Reich the
latter as you know being the
dictatorship smitten both both admired
and served as an incisive and articulate
friend of liberal democracy Dahl
effectively posed a similar question in
the ninth
in 50s and 1980s worried and I quote
that control over nuclear decisions is
emblematic of a larger issue he asked
whether again quote we have reached an
inherent limit on democracy thus whether
we have discovered a fundamental and
inescapable defect if so he continued
are we rationally obliged no matter how
much our deepest feelings may tug us
away from the dismaying conclusion to
commit ourselves to a non democratic
alternative at least over some set of
public policies of which policies about
nuclear weapons are perhaps only an
extreme example Dahl understood modern
American democracy not to be a system of
simple majority rule or the preserve of
a single elite making closed
determinations inaccessible to popular
influence but a complex system with many
rulers a polyarchy this American hybrid
he distinguished from dictatorship not
because the United States is governed by
the majority but because minorities he
said govern who vary in composition from
issue area to issue area including in
his early work national security in
America's system of endless bargaining
he argued in the preface to democratic
theory all the active and legitimate
groups in the population can make
themselves heard at some crucial stage
in the process of decision and it was
now exactly that that he put in question
posing Schmidt's question in dolls term
we might ask whether it's possible to
prevent the democratic process from
becoming hollow by preserving a
meaningful degree of final control
regarding the security centered arena of
exceptions for its central political
institutions and for the country's
citizens who wish to be heard at a
crucial stage in
process of decision how within the
framework of polyarchy might that be
accomplished now there is a view an
influential one to the effect that such
a quest the one I should like to address
in much of what remains of this lecture
is hopeless even innocent we are too
late that's the position taken in the
prominent writings by the Italian
philosopher Giorgio Agamben who poses a
challenge to liberal democracy in a
spirit of doubt and hostility at least
as far-reaching for our time as Carl
Schmitt s' was for his but as compared
to Schmitt agamben has been far more
suspicious of state power and far less
nostalgic for a lost liberal moment
Augmon been claims in a profound and
irreversible inversion that the zone of
exception has become so overwhelming it
to be dominant divorced from any
semblance of the rule of law his 2003
stato ill akechi own a gained global
attention when it appeared in English
two years later as state of exception
placing exception in what he called a
no-man's land between law and political
facts this drumbeat of a book insists
that liberal norms practices and
legality have been surmounted by the
primary zone of legal in illegality what
he calls legal in illegality an immense
sight of exception in regimes that call
themselves both democratic and liberal
the zone far larger and more central
than that Dahl had identified the
liberal tradition on this view has been
rendered helpless injecting dolls
nightmare with steroids
agon been conveyed the situation of
citizens as having degenerated so
significantly that there our
circumstances were
humble stateless persons divisions
between war and peace between legal and
political decisions have disappeared
liberal law itself he argued has become
the problem not the solution there is no
turning back to constitutionalism the
only remaining hope lies he argued with
a utopian vision of post liberal
political play a politics outside the
constraints of formal institutions now
this is a nightmare more total and more
terrifying than dolls are gone Ben's
dystopia insists that the exception a
foundationless location a sight of pure
violence without limitation or inherent
discipline has become the immovable
standard and any effort to navigate the
rule of law thus is hopelessly innocent
arguing that differences distinguishing
totalitarian absolutist and liberal
regimes have become indeterminate and
obsolete his analysis returned readers
to Rome but not to its Comus aerial
dictatorship that was discussed the
other day instead agamben highlighted a
more obscure less familiar less remarked
on institutional site the eye ustah
Tetum an empty space that suspended the
law to save the Republic rather than
concentrate the law with the fullness of
powers as in the case of the Roman
dictatorship he also focused on the octo
itas a Roman institution that deprived
Public Enemies of any legal standing
subjecting them outside the law to the
prospect of death at any moment this
zone not the Roman dictatorship is where
we find contemporary exceptions hogaan
been wrote quote an empty space in which
human action with no relation to law
stands before a law with no relation to
life and
quote this dark formulation is
consistent with earlier work in which he
designated Auschwitz as paradigmatic of
all of modernity rather than seeing it
as marking radical evil at the extreme
end of a continuum in the manner say of
Hana Arendt's remarkable discussion of
death camps in the origins of
totalitarianism which she designated as
the location where persons become
superfluous by announcing the state of
exception to be the dominant paradigm of
government in contemporary politics ah
gone been eliminated dividing lines
between citizens and Outsiders between
the liberal and the illiberal between
the Democratic and the authoritarian
between the arbitrary and systematic
lawfulness precisely the borders each
one of these lines is a border we need
to guard should Agha men be right
liberal democracy has become entirely
nugatory a trifling form without
meaningful substance even as it urgently
captured the worst of reality and
possibility his jarring analysis a form
of critical poetry cannot stand up to
scrutiny I think because it's a it's a
diatribe that suffocates distinctions
moving from imprisoning implications to
fantasy solutions state of exception
erases any boundary between the ordinary
and the exceptional something dull
rightly refused to do if agon been
eliminated prospects for liberal
democracy by rhetorical Fiat dolls more
neat nuanced and precise formulation in
its own way was more challenging unlike
a gun ban he insisted that we must ask
hard questions inside history and within
liberal democracy about the relationship
between the normal and the exceptional
as I observed yesterday Locke was among
the first to identify emergencies and
exceptions as fundamental challenges for
liberal regimes ever since these
problems have been present inside
liberal thought thus with Dahle we might
explore whether this stock of ideas
still offers resources notwithstanding
radically altered conditions resources
to help us navigate the rule of law
might it be possible to limit yet permit
a necessary zone of exception without
overwhelming liberal democracies most
cherished qualities can we confine the
scope of security and tame dolls
nightmare without descending to a
Gambon's the stakes are high in the
language of Arendt
do we have nothing to fall back on in
order to understand the phenomenon that
confronts us with its overpowering
reality and breaks down all the
standards we know and quote regarding
death camps perhaps not regarding
exigencies emergencies and exceptions I
believe we do and we must for otherwise
for otherwise liberal democracy has no
future well we continue to learn from
the puzzles posed and the solutions
offered by previous generations of
liberal thinkers today's challenges to
liberal constitutionalism cannot simply
be resolved by pointing to let alone
imitating prior answers we need fresh
thought and policy prescriptions to
discern how indeed if it might still be
possible as our colleague Bruce Ackerman
has proposed to design arrangements that
allow and I quote short-term emergency
measures but draws the line against
permanent restrictions is that likely in
an age of enduring exceptions if not and
I think probably not what might be done
this question is trying which ideas and
practices that is which rules might best
deploy constitutionalism law mechanisms
of account
ability and such values as due process
to serve security without undermining
fundamental liberal norms or inhibiting
means of learning and correction can
coordination and remedies be achieved
effectively without departing from
liberal democracies insistence that
rulers give reasons that decisions be as
transparent as possible and that
judgments be rendered as to whether the
public good has been indeed is being
served is it possible to appraise the
process of making choices and look back
to inquire if decisions were made
consistent with public liberties and
that conferred on citizens the capacity
to examine and critique their own
leaders more precisely how might the
combination of elements that discussed
yesterday that Algernon Sidney had put
on the table in 1680 things that he
thought to be essential his remember his
criteria were limited in time
circumscribed by law and kept
perpetually under the supreme authority
of the people how might the combination
of those elements the limited in time
circumscribed by law and kept
perpetually under the supreme authority
of the people can they be renewed and
with these criteria how as Sidney
underscored should the enabling ethical
conditions that guard these
institutional features be renewed in
order to prevent a liberal order from
changing character to slide on a moral
slippery slope last evening I noted that
the quest for standards to navigate this
problem has a long-standing lineage as I
said a moment ago again repeating myself
searching for resources with which to
undertake tasks of realism repair and
fortification we might specify how
despite present disorder
it still might be possible to adapt and
deploy at least some of the resources
offered by John Locke and Alexander
Hamilton and Abraham Lincoln as they
replied to Hobbes and those developed by
Friedrich Karl Friedrich and Frederick
Watkins and Clinton Rossiter as they
responded to Karl Schmitt perhaps as a
first step by revisiting those efforts
to answer Hobbes and Schmitt and by
applying them to the conditions for
institutional arrangements designated by
Algernon Sidney we can establish
persuasive principles to guide more
particular institutional recommendations
at stake is the ability to hold fast to
a distinction already familiar to the
founders the difference between the
flexible and the arbitrary flexibility
Dahl argued in his Abraham's lectures
requires that citizens possess three
capacities competence what he called
competence control and influence
competency argued is the moral and
instrumental ability to make adequately
enlightened judgments either about
policies or about the terms on which
authority to make decisions may safely
be delegated control demands that
citizens should be able to ensure and I
quote doll that the final decision
corresponds with their informed
intentions an influence obliges those to
whom authority is delegated to be
motivated to seek the goals implied by
the informed intentions of citizens or
the greater number of them rather than
merely their own interests or even their
own private conceptions of the public
good and quote to these ends doll called
for intensive public education and the
formation of deliberative opportunities
for representative groups of citizens
who had gained high competence and thus
could stand
for and represent others this is a very
Yale of a way of thinking if you think
of Jim fish kids work for example these
steps would address the criterion Sydnee
designated as quote kept perpetually
under the supreme authority of the
people but from the Vantage of enduring
exceptions this orientation of dolls
still left open the two other criteria
limited in time and circumscribed by law
to generate answers with respect to all
of Sidney's stipulations I sought
assistance in previous lectures from
within the range of liberal ideas dating
from luck it will be recalled how Locke
insisted that executive prerogative must
not be arbitrary or boundless decisions
taken through that time type of power
only prevail until the legislature can
convene and judge legitimation depends
on norms and popular judgments about the
public good popular sovereignty is
intended not only to empower but to
limit action in a good regime informed
and vigilant citizens are the ultimate
judges for Locke reserving the right to
rebel when a ruler utilizes prerogative
power to abuse not advance the public
good the founders that will be
remembered likewise insisted on
safeguards
these included the two-year limit on
congressional appropriations for the
military the centrality of legislative
consent the existence of checks by the
federal judiciary a commitment to
federalism notwithstanding its inherent
ambiguities regarding states rights and
the robust adversarial spirit of party
and public debate underpinned by shared
values committed to Liberty Lincoln we
know acted not just to protect but to
achieve the core principles of the
Declaration and the Constitution he
refused to suspend elections or
curb the press or limit public debate
about the war and emancipation on his
watch can Rick Congress acted
energetically without executive
interference to investigate and oversee
emergency powers thus did not erase but
advanced the deeply political aspects of
an open liberal democracy marked by
separation of powers even when it was
placed under ultimate pressure further
the twentieth-century American critics
of Schmitt including Watkins and
Rossiter and Friedrich required that
there be no departure from the rule of
law that exceptions must be specific and
targeted thus controlled in scope as
well as limited in time they relied on
public virtue representative
institutions and an active public sphere
in dramatic contrast to a Gambon and
Schmidt the constellation of liberal
thinkers also insisted and this point is
crucial that it is a mistake to accept
too radical a separation between the
domain of exceptions and the larger
regime within which this zone is
embedded and between a pre-existing
community and a legally constituted
political community it is the latter a
political community not a pre political
constellation which under duress
possesses the right to rebel these
points were underscored by President
Lincoln's advisor the German emigres
Francis Lieber in a recently
rediscovered manuscript on martial law
written during the three decades after
the Civil War and completed by his son
Nathan Lieber is best known for the code
he drafted to direct how Union soldiers
should conduct themselves with regard to
such matters as the expropriation of
property deserters spies the exchange of
prisoners martial law five months from
now Yale University Press will be
publishing this document
with an introduction by its editors will
smiley and our John wit where they
report how for the Leber's a state of
emergency and I quote does not throw a
constitutional regime back into the
state of nature certainly not when the
regime is a complex constitutional
democracy the libras crucial insight was
that the moment of emergency poses a
distinctive problem in collectivities
that constitute themselves through law
Schmitt imagined that the emergency
allowed the sovereign to reorganize a
collectivity that already had identity
independent of law the paradigmatic case
for Schmitt was the ethic ethnically
ethnically homogeneous community but in
legally constituted communities there is
no collective entity existing prior to
the laws to be saved by transforming the
law law makes the community so there is
nothing for the sovereign to rescue
other than that which the law has made
the manuscript by the levers also
teaches a second lesson equally
important that places us on dolls rather
than agon bends terrain as smiley and
whit observe unlike a Gambon as well as
Schmitt the libras stressed that the
moment of exception cannot escape the
assumptions cultural codes and folk ways
of the regime foundational features of
the regime inevitably shape the
project's interests and identity of
those who seize Authority in the
emergency the basic values of a
community's law thus travel into the
very depths of a crisis indeed they do
so inevitably thus they note quote a
Gambon's notion of a moment of bear and
unmediated power simply does not come
into being and quote yet alas it might
what may well come into being after
continuous and normalized exceptions is
that the Preferences of the people and
the character of the regime might change
so fundamentally that as in Rome a
former Republic may morph into Empire or
Comus aerial initiatives may transform
into solutions outside the
constitutional order collectively the
various rejoinders to Hobbes and Schmitt
and implicitly to agamben from lock
through Lieber and on to Rossiter
insisted that the rule of law both
shapes the community and when thickly in
place sets limits on what can be done in
a liberal democracy to confront pressing
exigencies Dahl you you will recall did
not only convey deep anxiety excuse me
it's water time excellent
Dahl you will recall did not only convey
deep anxiety about a zone of exception
aside normal democratic processes in his
1953 article on atomic energy he also
noted approvingly quote that the arrival
of nuclear weapons had not assuredly
pushed us to the edge of dictatorship
and he perceived how America's leaders
quote are quite patently not imposing a
tyrannical will on a terrified public
whether and how limits and constraints a
vibrant liberal democracy imposes matter
quite a lot then so the patrimony of
liberal thought is invaluable teaching
that there is no other basis for
exceptions but responsibilities for
liberty and that there must be no
departure from the rule of law our
ultimate guarantee against the great
nightmare of sovereign dictatorship yet
the worrying features of our
contemporary situation make it difficult
to confidently announce that
orientations proposed by liberals from
Locke forward can either be easily or
effectively guide our present policies
politics and actions the altered
conditions Dahl underscored require more
than 18th and 19th century models of
prerogative and more than
twentieth-century models of
constitutional dictatorship based on the
Roman model more than they can provide
each in its own way premise on the
assumption of a temporal arc that no
longer exists the trio of Hobbes Schmitt
and argon been haunts our vulnerability
responses and liberal answers have
become more pressing and more difficult
at a time of multiple bases of
insecurity including terror cyber and
the enduring threat of nuclear exchange
ever since dolls initial writing on
atomic power the sense of emergency has
become more open-ended
implied powers have developed in tandem
with ever more express exceptions and
there are scant requisite procedures to
place restrictions on presidents who
wish to act as if they are sovereign
dictators power has been increasingly
centralized the legislature often
abdicates delegates or is ignored the
number of decision makers has been
reduced secrecy often reigns judicial
review is limited surveillance
mechanisms grow and citizens grow either
docile and unsettled or positively
acclaim some of these developments in
the inverse of liberal norms citizens
become more visible the state less so
the status of private life and
autonomous citizenry has become muddled
never before has a zone of exceptions
developed cumulatively over an extended
period inside liberal democracy a site
designated
just by auntie liberals like Agamben but
by passionate liberals like Dahle
Eisenhower Obama and never before have
these arrangements seemed so foreboding
and menacing to liberal democracy itself
the zone of exceptions is also charged
with irony as an example the
authorization for use of military force
that Congress passed three days after
9/11 and which Presidents Bush and Trump
have interpreted expansively as
authorizing a continuing and open-ended
delegation to the President to combat
insecurity by any necessary means was
read more narrowly by President Obama as
we have seen he preferred to rely on in
the fight against terror on
constitutional article two powers
inherent in the presidency but one
result of his tighter reading almost
certainly without intention has been to
distance Congress even further from
executive decision and to elide the
process of political representation yet
the shift to a universe of national
security marked by durable and lasting
exceptions possesses some potential
advantages as pressures of necessity
extend the insulation of decision-makers
presents opportunities to coordinate and
deliberate over a more protracted period
with chances to consider to offer
reasons to guide public debate and
retrospectively evaluate and learn
vengeance may yield to reason regarding
how to navigate the continuum from risk
to deep uncertainty there may be times
as both Locke and Hamilton insisted when
necessity Trump's law but as they also
insisted such circumstances must be
constrained by prudence by institutional
arrangements by active regulation and
the goal of serving and advancing the
public good
we can see such considerations that work
in some of the best post-911 treatments
of emergency Powers think of the
significant writings many of you will
know of Dave and decent house or know me
Lazar who were interred degree here as
examples and in the policy imagination
of those like Bruce Ackerman who have
been considering what to do when leaders
must react to violent and intensely
dangerous developments not foreseen that
demand urgent response as his writing
reminds us debate generated by audacious
designs is valuable not least for the
invitation to debate both practical and
constitutional issues what we presently
lack however are prescriptions that
fully take current conditions into
account and respond to a Gambon's
critique the way our predecessors
responded to Hobbes and Schmitt rather
rather than erase the prospects for
liberal democracy as a gun bender X we
must navigate were challenged to
navigate the space that both separates
and connects the arena of exceptions to
more ordinary liberal democratic sites
Machiavelli famously thought that
provisions for crises must be placed
wholly inside constitutional procedures
in a republic it is not good for
anything to happen he wrote which
requires governing by extraordinary
measures the American approach by
contrast has been different though the
Constitution was born in crisis apart
from the suspension of habeas corpus
during an invasion or internal rebellion
that document is either silent or
implicit regarding emergencies and
exceptions like Locke Second Treatise it
placed prerogative power outside formal
and constitutional stipulation but
relies on the president's implied and
stipulated powers how we thus have to
ask should content and barriers be
identified at just that location
manifestly there's need for sober reason
to this end I'll close with some
preliminary very preliminary thoughts
which I first want to pose as questions
and then make some suggestions first is
it possible to read ascribe key aspects
of reality without falsehood in order to
sustain indeed reinvigorate the
distinction that was so central to the
Roman model separating temporary action
from permanent policy which arrangements
might propose this useful fiction
separating the temporary from the
permanent second is it possible to
discern and develop widely shared
Prudential standards including
definitions of necessity in advance in
order to be to legitimately anticipate
and respond to security emergencies with
what content what breath breath with a D
what bite third how should the core
institutions of liberal democracy
especially the legislature be mobilized
to better conduct tasks of instruction
to the executive and oversight of its
action what instruments do parliaments
including Congress possess or could come
to possess to advance that prospect and
fourth perhaps most important can we
create opportunities for retrospective
judgment and appraisal in order to
modify shape and constrain the zone of
exception if liberal democracy thrives
as an instrument for provisional policy
judgments how can procedures for
learning be institutionalized and what
and might just such mechanisms
strengthen a widely shared liberal
political culture without which they
might not be of much use so let me speak
to each of these four sets of questions
in turn before I conclude persisting
threats notwithstanding leaders can act
I believe must act as if the division
between permanent and temporary
interventions remains actively
functional one way to achieve that goal
is by requiring legislative relevant
legislative acts and delegations to be
fixed in time always subject to formal
renewal such a requirement stressed by
Hamilton is hardwired in the
Constitution to the effect that military
expenditures cannot be authorized and
appropriated for periods longer than two
years only when in this manner
legislation characterized by significant
delegation contains provisions for
sunset can consequential debates about
the degree of necessity and the scope of
exception be conducted among political
elites and more broadly in the press the
media and by the public within civil
society further as Francis Lieber argued
emergency actions by the government
should be appraised by what his
rediscovered manuscript calls a
reasonable citizens standard based on
the imagined judgment of persons who are
quote moderate and reasonable this is a
standard asking whether measures to deal
with exigencies are proportionate to the
actual threat quote when reason and
common sense do not approve the
particular act this is a quote from
Lieber the act becomes unlawful with all
the consequences attending to
illegalities end quote with comments
John Witt comments that quote the
reasonable person thus turned the moment
of necessity into a moment
which the ends and means to be adopted
by the state were continually
constituted and reconstituted necessity
in libres hands was not merely a warrant
for harsh measures though it could
sometimes be that it was instead a
discursive frame for means-ends
reflective equilibrium a way of
organizing and restructuring the process
by which we decide who we are in the
midst of an emergency politics of
exception must not pretend invisibility
or isolation from democratic practices
to the contrary each branch of
government especially the legislature
but also the judiciary and agencies
within the executive branch itself must
possess opportunities for information
sharing judgment and supervision in real
time
contemporaneous oversight in the
tradition of the separation of powers we
must recall lies at the heart of
America's constitutional design for
government a government meant not to be
predatory here the role of Congress is
crucial we badly need assessments from
students of Congress not least the most
distinguished of them professor Mayhew
we badly need assessments of such
students of Congress together with
members and their staffs about how to
change the incentive structures that
presently makes congressional
representatives reluctant to restrain
decide and oversee with respect to
national security and what happens after
the fact is there room for post hoc
appraisal this question calls for
systematic reconnaissance perhaps the
most feasible and most important of all
potential steps post emergency learning
and evaluation tied to sanctions when
liberal norms have been violated
might help confine the scope of
exceptions to that of necessity as
defined by democratic reason
and robust representation consider
specific examples of retrospective
evaluation drawn from Great Britain's
institutional complex unlike the United
States there exist British institutions
that demonstrates significant
retroactive and reflective possibilities
none navigates the terrain perfectly but
they possess far more fluidity and
creativity than the arrangements
currently available here in the United
States the most traditional of these
institutions quite similar in many ways
to constitutional committees on
intelligence is Parliament's
Intelligence and Security Committee like
its American counterparts the ISC
questions security and intelligence
analysts and private tends to defer to
government identifies closely with the
security agencies and issues only
heavily redacted public reports
notwithstanding on occasion it far more
audaciously questions heads of the
security services in public it has
defended privacy concerns regarding bulk
surveillance and has reported to the
public on the country's drone strikes
more than the United States Britain
possesses a significant tradition of
public reports and large-scale enquiries
in matters of national security
2006 for an exam as an example witnessed
the publication by the Cabinet Office of
quote the national security strategy of
the United Kingdom guided it said and
grounded in a set of core values I quote
they include human rights the rule of
law legitimate and accountable
government justice freedom tolerance and
opportunity while considering
instrumental means many at the edge of
these values to keep the country safe
though such a document did not solve the
relationship between the two it was able
to generate discussion about how to
chart a core
after the Iraq war more autonomous from
sitting governments is the tradition of
independent enquiries dating from the
tribunal of inquiry act of 1921 that
began modestly with the investigation of
particular police constables the range
over time has been brought including
River Safety health emergencies and
national security in 2004 a review was
conducted regarding intelligence on
weapons of mass destruction and why
things went wrong in Iraq a report that
found major flaws the most recent
example of such a report as the 12
volume 2.6 million word Iraq inquiry led
by Sir John Chilcott published in 2016
with an inexpensive 225 page executive
summary a summary that our sitting
president probably would not read this
2016 report conveyed to the public the
stinging results of an extraordinarily
thorough investigation that lasted seven
years arguing that the case for war and
the legal basis had been deficient
preparation was inadequate the results
of failure press coverage was extensive
for weeks
it was the prevalent story now more
original and demanding so more original
and demanding particularly close study
and potential emulation is what I
believe to be a globally unique
institution the investigatory powers
tribunal a 10-member body that has been
in existence since 2000 created by the
regulation of Investigatory Powers Act
complaints can be made to the tribunal
by members of the public and NGOs about
interception and surveillance by the
police or other public authorities or
about the conduct by the security agency
he's thought to be outside the law
particularly in cases brought by NGOs
the investigatory powers tribunals just
retired presidents or Michael Burton has
written it has now become the practice
of the tribunal to hold open hearings
with full open argument with eminent
council expert in Human Rights appearing
before us we are no longer described as
Britain's most secret Court we have
developed this procedure in national
security cases of assuming the facts in
favor of the claimant a claimant
including an NGO is entitled to bring a
claim without proof of what is alleged
simply on the basis of reasonable
suspicion and the facts are assumed in
his favor and the tribunal then
considers whether on those assumptions
the conduct complained of is lawful
after open hearings the tribunal reports
this decision in an open judgement and
the legal conclusion can then be applied
to the actual facts this Burton
continued and I quote gives us
considerable advantage over the
statutory commissioners and the
parliamentary committees because we can
hear adversarial argument balancing the
public need for security against the
need for public scrutiny the interests
of privacy and free speech and quote
there have been quite dramatic outcomes
leading to rebukes of the government and
to public disclosure of much that was
previously closed particularly the rules
and procedures under which the agencies
operated without the IPT and the
government believe sacrifices to
national security
the closest American analog perhaps is
the FISA Court but it's circumspection
and limitations including if secrecy are
legion navigating tensions between
security and freedom is a process not a
matter that can be decisively resolved
there is no single or poor
both solution to governing emergency in
a liberal frame instituting similar
procedures in the United States or any
other liberal polity would pose distinct
legal and political challenges
likewise policy responses to present
conditions will be variously inflected
by expectations values and dispositions
about the order of political priorities
I should like to offer the last word to
Yale's
Frederick Watkins Robert dolls senior
colleague and from whom he always said
he learned a great deal writing in 1939
Watkins observed that ever since ancient
Rome's most constant sorry that ever
since ancient Rome most constitutional
states have quote considered wise to
provide some regular means for the
suspension of normal political
procedures in the face of temporary
crises
despite this timeless reality he
continued quote there seldom has been a
time when emergency institutions loomed
so large as they do today in the realm
of actual practice 1939 he noted as a
student of the Third Reich that when
regimes claim absolute power they have
no need to appeal for social and
representative approbation
he further took note of the fragility of
liberal alternatives quote the
spectacular doings of Hitler and his
associates he wrote should not be
allowed to make us forget that this
Germany was a country once reckoned is
one of the more important seats of
modern constitutionalism
[Music]
sorry about that
one of the more important seats of
modern constitutionalism with a
government that in the 1920s had
conducted many experiments a good many
successful with emergency powers at the
start of World War two Watkins concluded
that there exists a deep need in liberal
political orders not to observe means to
confront the enemies of liberal
democracy but for liberal democracies to
identify and I quote effective
safeguards against the abuse of
emergency powers what he could not have
known was how matters that loomed so
large in 1939 soon would take the more
enduring form that doll would identify a
decade and a half later today we know
yet more as citizens who face a range of
exigencies in an age of terrible weapons
and networks of terror that mutate but
endure as we try to chart a decent
course we would do worse than consider
as our lodestar the imperatives
announced by Algernon Sidney's 1680
discourses concerning government limited
in time circumscribed by law and kept
perpetually under the supreme authority
of the people thank you
[Applause]
questions wait for the only sunlight in
person versus the current period which
is more decentralized terrorism Oh
upsets of different kinds but they don't
have sort of simple centralizing aspect
so great question it's a it's actually a
flaw of my three days of remarks that I
haven't made that distinction there's a
way in which the distinction is very
important in the way in which it's not
important I'll start with the not
important the the not important that
seems to me is that the way in which the
national government the National State
responded to the atomic situation
starting even when the United States
possessed a monopoly and especially
after 1949 when the monopoly ended and
cold war was raging wasn't so cold after
Korea and when the use it should be said
we now know from reading myself have
read many once classified National
Security Council papers when the use of
those weapons was actively being
considered again and again the the march
to his own of exceptions was one that
Dahl wrote about in 1953 is essay was
only
atomic weapons but he announced the
worry that this zone might expand and
where there's where the distinction
doesn't produce a difference is that the
ways in which we have responded to let's
call it the quote War on Terror
situation without commenting on whether
that's the right language or not but to
the diffuseness the number of non-state
actors the the unpredictability the
personal sense of it not that many
people get killed by terrorists compared
to other ways of being killed but it
feels very personally threatening in a
way that atomic warfare doesn't quite
though it should and the but the
response to that it's been much the same
that is to create a growing zone of of
exceptions outside what's all called the
ordinary processes of democracy and this
extends not only as extended not only
through congressional delegation and and
a legislative action it's extended to
creating autonomous zones of bureaucrats
those who listen to phone calls or those
who worry about the mail or and so on
and so forth who have been rather for
most of the period had been rather
unconstrained so the the this expanded
zone of exceptions has existed and it's
expanded both under the atomic impulse
and a call to terror impulse and of
course the atomic impulse has not gone
away it's not as if we've solved that
problem and have just moved on to the
next but I think the distinction matters
quite a lot because it matters in at
least the following number of ways I'm
now thinking out loud first it matters
for how for the nature of the
relationship between leaders and
citizens and how
anxiety is mobilized there can be
mobilized how fear can be created and
mobilized or more responsibly how fear
can be dampened and turned to more
ordinary levels of anxiety some of you
know one of my favorite distinctions was
made by the economist Frank Knight all
the way back in 1921 in a book on called
risk and uncertainty and profit where he
distinguished between ordinary risk and
deep uncertainty and ordinary risk is
its calculable because it's risk within
a set of fixed parameters the atomic
Cold War moment with deterrence theory
and the let and the like seemed like
that to the Henry Kissinger's of the
world let's just say um but then there's
circumstances that generate deep anxiety
and even fear which occur because we we
we think we've lost control of the
parameters and ironically even though
atomic warfare is far more potentially
threatening to all of us certainly to
the planet as a whole
then the levels of Terror which we've
witnessed the more personal qualities
have led more people to think we don't
control the parameters and therefore
were more fearful disproportionate to
the actual threat so that's a important
difference and then finally I think a
second important difference is that we
in a way it's easier though I put it put
a question mark after my each of my
declarative sentences it's it's easier
to take the way in which atomic weapons
have been managed and put them as to all
thought they were being in a separate
zone
necessary but also isolated from the
ordinary processes of democratic life
thus leaving them more or less intact so
doll could write his little essay on
atomic danger and write a preface the
Democratic theory at exactly the same
time without referring back and forth
because they were separate zones whereas
it's possible that the terror
circumstance creates aspects of
exception both in rhetoric and in policy
that become more constitutive of
everyday processes and in that sense
potentially more insidious to liberal
democracy so thanks what wait for the
mic this difference between Britain and
the u.s. that's been there for quite a
long time from the 1920s through the
chalk report system of institutional
management and I were just wondering if
you had anything to say about why why do
you think Britain has managed to produce
these kinds of policing institutions
that are more effective than the ones
um yet another good and challenging
question i'ma let me modify the premise
of the question although the the
tradition of open and public
retrospective reports dates from the
1921 act for the first few decades it
didn't deal with the kinds of issues you
know they really people make complaints
about how constables and Liverpool were
policing the port at night and there'd
be a parliamentary sanctioned
independent investigation but it's
really since 2001 and since Iraq that
you really see the ratcheting up I think
of that public inquiry tradition though
mamaan very thin ice here in terms of
getting the history right but that is
for the period between say the mid 1930s
to the to our century I just don't know
enough but the I think in Britain where
you see I've seen an escalation of this
was the profound recoil against what
seemed like a manifest caving or
subordination to the Bush administration
decisions about Iraq and that led to
sufficient public outrage and
parliamentary outrage that the existing
tools including the independent kind of
report that Chilcott produced 2 million
words and so on was activated so I think
it was a combination of situation the
nature of alliance and the recoil of
both and both parties in Parliament and
three parties if you like in Parliament
and in the public that gave that umph
but the but the structure already
existed the other thing that's new
the investigatory powers tribunal only
dates from this century and it has only
really come in - as far as I can tell
full life I've now read most of its
decisions over a period certainly since
the Iraq war but even even more recently
and and mostly to deal with the sense
that the way in which mi5 and mi6 have
dealt with the terrorist situation has
often exceeded proper rule of law and I
should add one thing and to how they
work which interest me a lot so imagine
you believe as the head of an NGO that
you've been your phone's have been
tapped your mails been listened to
you've been chased around
inappropriately you bring a complaint
the first question the investigatory
powers tribunal asks is not whether you
as I said not whether the facts back you
up let's assume you're right first
question is there any warrant for this
behavior in an act of Parliament so are
they just freewheeling or is it grounded
in in the ordinary rules of the game of
parliamentary sovereignty if the answer
is no that is there is no warrant they
issue a public rebuke and the persons
who bring the complaint get substantial
damages and it's a public rebuke the the
second step is let's assume there is
parliamentary warrant and most they have
legislation like the Patriot Act and so
on which gives a lot of space second
question if if there is a warrant did
the institution say mi5 or something did
it follow that law by elaborating a set
of regulations more detailed than the
law which are consistent with the intent
of the law
and if if the sense is no they didn't it
was a kind of runaway agent they took
the you know Carl Schmitt says I got men
say it's just a hollow law it's a it's a
cover it's a phony law well if they find
that the agency acted as if it's a phony
law they issue a public rebuke and they
and damages third step okay there are
such regulations did the agency act
according to its own regulations in
pursuing this instance doesn't always
follow you could have them but not act
on them did they exceed their regulatory
authority again if the answer is they
violated that there's a public rebuke
and damages there's a the way in which
they worked has actually changed the way
in which bulk surveillance occurs in
Great Britain they also ruled on this
may become obsolete soon on the
relationship of how a Britain works in
this security area and how European
courts the European justice system
insists you operate and so on and so
forth but rule of law really matters
here and it's reinforced in a way that
has a public learning quality and as far
as I know there been no judgments made
that have been resisted or treated as a
legitimate or as if you like fake news
by those in power of either party even
as they've been very unpleasant for some
of the time for them so that's a that's
that's a new process it doesn't date
forever and full disclosure the the
person I quoted Sir Michael Burton who
was a High Court judge now retired the
head of this institution is my son's
father-in-law and hence I so I may have
been captured by this source but but but
thanks to him I've you know
had access to lots of interesting
documentation and I've actually been
impressed by the way in which these this
this Tribunal of ten all all actual a
former or current High Court judges
conduct themselves and I simply observe
I maybe I'm missing something but I
can't think of any equivalent
institution we have presently in the
United States is that does that be right
Susan demos imagine demagogic leader and
a inflamed public anxious in the world
with the use of ultimate ultimate power
I would be inclined to resist the idea
that ninety percent support for doing
that as any question would be for you
that's hope that's not just a good
question that's a really hard question
the the the best of the Yale tradition
I'm not be clear I'm not arguing that
issues of security war and peace
danger up for you know brexit like
referenda that let's go to the people
all the time and ask because whether or
not you have demagogic leaders that
would open up to demagogy you know you
don't make public policy about most
things but certainly not fateful
security decisions
simply by in effect the kind of public
opinion poll right having said that I
still would stand by the quote again
from Algernon Sidney the ultimately
under the supreme authority of the
people and the supreme authority people
is not necessarily the same as public
opinion polling or referenda it's more
in the spirit of a lock on prerogative
power who says yes the executive must
act independently under conditions of
exigency but the people retrospectively
have a right to judge whether that
action was carried out in the under for
the public good and that is a
retrospective judgment taken in cooler
times not in the heat of the emergency
so a retrospective look at whether it
was a retrospective look at American
participation in World War one or a
retrospective look on the Iraq war seems
to me that that has potentially real
meaning but also provided the three
criteria that doll in his 1984 lectures
underscored in terms of how to make for
a more informed citizenry so there are
conditions of rationality information
and temporality that it seems to me
would condition the the role the people
would play not a role that of you know
passion under duress which says go get
them no matter no matter what
so all of the things you've mentioned
today and the and they're very
interesting and I think through the
institutional balances them may be
better to do without but the question I
had was something you mentioned
yesterday too is that behind whether
these institutions work partially
depends also on existing popular norms
and intuitions and I guess and
especially as you say the two sites that
seem to not work as checks I think so
them the expansion of executive power is
a congressional delegation and I guess
the question is pop where's the people
there because one of the things you
mentioned over the last few days is that
the moment of counter the 70's or the
few moments where there was a counter
movement it was driven by popular
outrage and support or popular protest
and so I guess the one question is where
where do you think well are we in a
moment in where there is any popular
outrage and if there isn't why isn't
there because I do think it kind of gets
to this other question of you know you
also said that part of the reason and I
don't have to go back to read though the
Rosses are in the walk things like why
the those ideas of constitutional
dictatorship may not apply or the
solutions they suggest
because we live in a time of more
enduring exception or at least a time of
perception of enduring exceptions so and
especially in America so this of course
is the irony it's probably the as you
say it you've said a few times it's the
least it's one of the least likely
places to suffer from terrorist attacks
around the world and the West in general
is least likely that any average citizen
so is it do citizens actually fear I
mean are they actually experiencing more
insecurity actually or is there you know
where's the psychology of fear that's
allowing the claims of an enduring
exception and I guess part of that is
getting back to whether you really think
our contemporary situation is so
distinct from the 50s or from you know
the invention of bombs and at the turn
of the 19th century that that the
Constantino that the the actual checks
have to be very different
is it something specific about a
psychological sense of insecurity that
may be new but it needs to also be you
know maybe we do need these public
discussions to have a real engaged and
informed public debate about about this
but I'm just curious where do you think
the people the people are there's a lot
there and what you're asking I want to
start with the temporal question because
there's a counter argument which I've -
the whole structure of my talk which you
hinted at which I'm trying to think
through at least until this moment
privately think it through but now there
been moments for example the first
appearance of the airplane with the bomb
making civilians vulnerable in a way
that was completely unprecedented occurs
in the first war or the incredible
intensification of artillery that occurs
prior to that one can go through moments
of stepwise changes in in the technology
of violence
but on that score the stepwise change to
atomic and nuclear weapons and this was
dolls insight and I think it's right was
so qualitatively different as to make it
not impossible but much less possible to
treat security situations in the model
of the Roman dictatorship as temporary
because that was not going away now of
course airplanes weren't going away and
tanks weren't going away and machine
guns weren't going away but the episodes
of use could be contained and the even
the terrible outcome of use even as bad
as the first war could be said to have
stopped and people could have talked the
language of a return to normalcy and he
made the argument there's no return to
normalcy and I think that's right now
what's interesting and it's a puzzle I
don't understand is if I did research
some of you know in the wrote about the
period that included the Truman years
and in that period atomic fear in the
mass public was palpable
Life magazine ran series of articles as
I mentioned the other day I think of
missiles before there weren't such
missiles hitting New York City and the
only thing left standing were the two
lions in front of the public library the
when a John Hersey wrote Hiroshima it
was broadcast for seven nights running
on ABC radio prime time that kind of
discourse about atomic fear is more or
less disappeared in this country we
don't talk about it we talk about the
war on terror or possibly so there's a
real puzzle there about what happened to
that dimension of fear but I think part
of the answer about where we are now and
why there isn't either out ray
or movement or concern or pushback of
the kind that we had in the 70s I think
has two reasons and once again I'm
playing with things I haven't thought
through first the 19 in the 19 really
the the pushback comes before 1976 it
already starts with the war War Powers
Act of 1973 and hearings before that
it's Vietnam War which for tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
Americans was a war of personal
vulnerability and even for those of us
who got deferments it was a personal
evolved durability the the war on terror
doesn't generate anything like that for
in a direct way over many years and so
on so back to Susan's question about you
know what's personal and what's not
Vietnam was both impersonal and personal
all at once and it generated a movement
and a general movement that had
electoral consequences as well as the
end of the Johnson presidency among
other things so that that force doesn't
exist and so that's one critical
difference and a second IIIi think that
the 9/11 shock you know yes three
thousand people are so killed as opposed
to bah-bah-bah
but the idea in a media age you could
watch over and over those planes flying
into the iconic World Trade Center
people jumping out you know etc I
actually think that in as endured as a
as an image well beyond Oklahoma City or
other domestic or kids being killed in
classrooms and and so on and so forth
and it was
conveyed a sense of vulnerability
because unlike the atomic age of the
Cold War as I said before the parameters
of risk don't seem didn't seem
controllable who the hell will they get
there and and in airplanes smashing the
World Trade Center
so inconceivable that it transcends the
objective numbers or probabilities in
some ways and that has given warrant not
just to say bush unitary executive views
and so on but gave warrant to Obama to
go after an American citizen without
kill them without trial in Yemen this
was another big extension of you know
the meaning of a rule of law and
citizenship and without any pushback
perhaps some might argue maybe I would
argue if I thought if I knew more that
it was not even a stupid thing to do but
the but the steps that have been taken
and further the last thing I would say
I'm sorry to go on so long it seems to
me that the the changes we're witnessing
here are kind of salami like slices if
you add up they've been I don't know
tens of executive orders of various
kinds and well over ten major
congressional pieces of legislation
since 9/11 on these subjects and each
one you know accumulates without the
whole ever being held up to view as the
central problem for liberal democracy
what defines the Emergencies anybody
present can decide on any
that's a great great question and now
the everybody hear the question who
decides that it's an emergency
well let's distinguish first something
objective happens magic I mean that is
either this pure fiction or something
occurs but then it has to be interpreted
and it's in the interpretation that it
becomes an emergency okay
typically in in a liberal democracy
elected officials interpret and they've
been in effect delegated by the public
through election as people to be trusted
now really interesting that in the Roman
model of dictatorship that I've spoken
about the dictator was not the person
the dictator who could serve only for
six months and only for the emergency
was not a person who was eligible to
declare that it was an emergency but we
have a consequent our president can
declare that it's an emergency
and then becomes in effect the quote
dictator for that period for that
function so we were less well-off in
terms of being able to guard this
question of an excessive definition of
emergency
[Applause]
you